bon je vous explique l' espion
soviétique qui l'ont arrêté on veut que
vous défendiez l'acte d'accusation je ne
suis pas sûr de vouloir y toucher
l'accusé n'a pas d'avocat dans ses
relations la cour fédérale nous a collé
la faire le conseil de l'ordre a voté
vous êtes choisi à l'unanimité
c'était important pour nous c'est
important pour notre pays estime qu'on
voit que cet homme a droit à un procès
loyal c'est la justice américaine qu'on
jugera oui évidemment
présenté comme ça c'est un honneur bien
sûr mais vous line je défends des
assurances je n'ai pas plaider au pénal
depuis des lustres
c'est comme se remettre au vélo venant
vous vous étiez distingué à nuremberg
mais j'étais dans l'équipe de
l'accusation pas la question
le droit pénal ne vous est pas étranger
jim regarder la situation
l'homme est publiquement vilipendé et je
le serai aussi oui dans les milieux mal
informés
c'est exactement pour ça qu'il faut le
faire et le faire dans les règles sinon
20 croire que notre système judiciaire
traite les affaires par dessus la jambe